20-18 was a pretty rotten year for stock
market investors it's been a fairly long
bull market in America really since
March 2009 what I mean by bull market is
share prices have risen pretty steadily
without a very big setback so chair
prices in America have raced away from
pretty much everywhere else from Europe
from Japan from emerging markets America
has really been the place where stock
mark investors have wanted to be the
question is is that going to be true in
2019 in a market that's coming pretty
mature now going into its tenth year is
there really very much upside from US
stocks anymore you might want to start
looking somewhere else looking at Europe
looking at emerging markets which
haven't been rising quite as quickly and
therefore a cheap and not better value
the other way of looking at things to
say if things are getting risky after a
pretty awful year like 2018
I might just want to double down all the
things they've done well for me so far
stick with America stick with technology
stocks so-called Fang that's Facebook
Apple Amazon Netflix and Google these
are the companies that investors think
are going to do well not just for the
next few years but for the next few
decades the problem with that view is it
does rely on the US economy continuing
to do better than economies elsewhere
most people think next year will be a
slower year for US economic growth
the Chinese economy has actually been
slowing down and that's not just because
of Donald Trump's trade wall there's
also been an underlying slowdown in
consumer spending in the Chinese economy
and that hasn't just affected China
that's affected all the local emerging
markets in Asia and it's also affected
Europe about a third of the profits that
European listed companies make come
either from China or from other emerging
markets that are tied into China
so when China slows Europe slows as well
the Chinese government is worried about
the degree to which the economy has been
slowing so it's been trying to gee up
the economy a little bit by cutting
taxes by relaxing monetary policy and by
spending more on infrastructure if that
starts to percolate through into the
Chinese economy next year you could also
see growth picking up in economies that
rely heavily on Chinese demand in Asia
but also in Europe
Hof investors think is best to stick
with the US market and half of investors
think it will be better to look
elsewhere for growth we're looking
forward here and we don't really know
what's going to happen in 2019 investors
always have to deal with uncertainty
what's the best way to deal with that
well in general it makes sense to try
and spread your bets widely not to put
all your eggs in one basket as investors
have been doing with the American market
buy a basket of stocks that gives you
exposure to a wide range of emerging
markets and also a basket of stocks that
gives you exposure to a lot of rich
economies outside America
that's Europe and Japan and Australia
spread your best is probably the best
strategy for 2019